winning big brother canada is hard
fortunately i'm pretty smart early on i
want to diminish my threat level make
the other house guests laugh and frankly
just be great to live with later in the
game i want to find the people i trust
and slit the throats of everybody who i
don't if i'm in the finals i can make a
fantastic case to win this game getting
there won't be easy but if i'm there
winning will be
so you've definitely thought about this
i've thought a lot about how to win this
game that said
it's season 10. they're gonna throw some
twists our way but because i have such
good control of my emotions and of who i
am i need to take a second think about
how to play these twists and use that
mental fortitude to my advantage
um what kind of personality would you
clash with in the house
i'm probably gonna clash with a lot of
people in the house
i think i'm gonna have trouble getting
along with anybody from
smaller towns who have less life
experience who haven't really ever left
home and this is like the biggest thing
they've ever done in their lives
i don't do well with people who are
putting on a front
like even though i'm gonna be lying a
little bit i'm pretty good at seeing
through that in other people
if there is anybody who i think is
smarter than me somehow
i am going after them
or no man
nomads
i am not into showmances i've been in a
relationship for a really long time
almost seven years i'm actually gonna
bend that truth a little bit and say
that we're married i think it's a good
way to build early trust especially with
the older house guests or house guests
with children
so no man's for me
because i'm taken why is canada gonna
root for you this season
i'm not sure if canada's gonna root for
me often they're rooting against the
villain
you can't assume how people are
interpreting things until you're out of
the house so i'm playing my game i'm
trying to win and i'm not thinking too
much about canada liking or disliking me